well I've been involved in boxing and
boxing related matters for the better
part of thirty three years it's in my
blood
my father did this his father did this
and so to his father's father's father I
was four years old cut my hand playing
with my step past table song she was a
woodworker and I was finishing up a
corner shelf I panicked and did the only
thing a 4yo would do grab my hand
pastrami soap that he cascade and set it
on fire
I'm harvelle Jenkins I'm a cop man I
would enjoy to help especially people
that have excruciating pain
face to spawn a crack-up can't see you
pissing blood real pain
yeah I could have been a doctor but my
methods unorthodox climbing square
circle choice
come have job is 12 I tend to uh fight
immune to physical deterioration
throughout a fight in essence I may be
able to save the title or give him the
chance of still endure on every great
cup man is a great corner me one hand
Walsh it up but my corner man nineteen
years ago Jim's a deli my hometown of
Baltimore around here somewhere
when I met him he was eaten what is
arguably the biggest goddamn sandwich
I've ever seen [ __ ] was hanging out
besides he had dressing running off at
home and a scuffle broke out Teddy took
the pro ball and clubbed a big son of a
[ __ ] across his face from then on I
knew the Teddy loons of the man I wanted
to work with for life